des pâtes du chocolat ou encore des
produits d'hygiène l'union des étudiants
des yvelines organisé une distribution
gratuite de produits de première
nécessité dans le hall du bâtiment
vauban à l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines clairement il
ya plus viable beaucoup plus de monde
ces souffrances mais on a vraiment une
grosse que comme ça mais elles
généralement au bout d'une heure vers
des amplis là elle est aussi grande
depuis qu'on a commencé grâce aux dons
récoltés devant le carrefour market et
la biocoop de montigny le bretonneux le
syndicat met à disposition une tonne de
produits selon une enquête de l'union
nationale des étudiants de france le
coût de la vie étudiante a augmenté de
6,47 % j'ai pris des féculents parce que
ça ça va me tenir genre un mois par
exemple parce qu'il propose pas mal de
choses là j'ai pris des pâtes j'ai pris
de la purée j'ai pris des conserves
également j'ai du mal parce que avec par
exemple un budget 200 euros par mois ou
même mois t'as pas grand chose dans ton
frigo ni dans ses placards en fait moi
je suis d'abord
vous étudiez des mamans et j'ai trois
enfants et c'est un peu difficile pour
balancer entre étudiants font donc c'est
en actionnant ça va nous aider un petit
peu a soulagé un peu leurs fins de mois
au delà de la précarité alimentaire ce
qui inquiète beaucoup le syndicat c'est
la précarité menstruel elle toucherait
une étudiante sur trois franchement je
pense qu'il y en a peut-être une ou deux
sur la qui en ont pas pris sur je ne
sais pas combien je pense que vous avez
vu la queue ce qui est assez
problématique c'est que si on leur
propose pas l os paraît ce qui est
compréhensible mais il ya plus une gêne
à prendre un jeu tout à l'heure il ya
deux filles qui parlent entre elles
pendant six ans wayne ans un peu la
honte et tout mais au final en leur
temps et puis c'est bon et pour faire
face à ces difficultés sylvie retailleau
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
a annoncé la revalorisation des bourses
sur critères sociaux de 4% celle des
aides au logement de 3,5 pour cent ainsi
que le prolongement du titre restaurant
à en euros pour les plus précaires mais
pour le syndicat de l'union des
étudiants des yvelines ce n'est pas
suffisant avec d'autres universités de
france il milite pour un revenu
étudiants à 1102 euros par mois